foreign
's YouTube channel my name is raneem
Rashid and I'm a blockchain trainer at
simply learn and we do provide trainings
in terms of blockchain development and
application and architecture before
starting our today's session just please
make sure that you subscribe and hit the
like button for the video so that you
don't miss any update from us so today's
topic that we will be discussing is
about how do you become a blockchain
developer and it's one of the most
frequently asked questions that I have
encountered as well for most of the
people coming from different backgrounds
it's not only from only technical for
only people from coming from technical
side but also someone from a very
different industry and they are quite
interested in joining uh the blockchain
domain in terms of how they can build
something that can change the whole game
of how we do the transactions and these
things so um we are going to discuss a
little bit about
um what could be the kind of steps or
what could be the ways that you can be a
blockchain developer and before going
into the uh discussion of what are the
ways for that first we must need to
understand who is a blockchain developer
itself because there are quite different
terms that being used like some of you
maybe have heard about smart contract
engineer or blockchain engineer or our
blockchain developer so these are
different terms that's being used
interchangeably so along with it you
must need to know the the main uh
understanding and the terms are being
used and what is the meaning of being a
blockchain developer so moving forward
we are going to discuss a kind of what
could be a type of blockchain developers
on which side you can focus and then you
are going to explore some of the steps
that how you can become and how you can
be planning your journey to become a
blockchain developer as a as your career
so uh we are we'll be moving forward in
in terms of also just exploring a little
bit about the market that was the salary
range that's being provided and I kind
of you can say obstacles that is for
someone who wants to learn blockchain
development or who wants to learn this
technology so this is a kind of our
whole agenda that what we will be
discussing in our today's uh session so
first of all let me first move forward
with the kind of questions that who is a
blockchain developer so initially what I
would say whenever you want to achieve
something or you whenever you you plan
to get yourself into as a part of your
career as a part of your next role first
of all you shouldn't understand some of
the questions and you should ask
yourself a few questions who what and
why you want to be uh to be that
position so that's very important first
of all you do try to understand who you
want to be like who who is a blockchain
developer who is a kind of position that
you are looking for then what are the
ways to become that specific
professional in the market and then why
also you should know that why you are
looking forward to be yourself be a part
of this industry or be a part of this
domain that's quite very important
questions that you should ask yourself
not going to answer anyone but ask
yourself and satisfy yourself with these
answers the reason is that that is going
to compose your whole goal or whole
motivation for the uh for your whole
career journey in the terms let's say if
you know that why you are planning to be
a blockchain developer what is your
reason to be in this industry what is
your main motivation you will be stayed
on the whole track and you can plan
these things in a real way or you can
say in a kind of you will have some
timeline that you wanted to achieve that
you wanted to be in this domain so make
sure that you do ask these three
questions before getting into any XYZ
technology it's not just related to
blockchain it's a general kind of three
questions that I usually make sure that
I am clear enough why I'm going into
this direction so that's just my
personal opinion or a kind of my
personal uh belief that I should know
that okay why I want want it to be there
and what could be the ways and who I am
going to be so as a part of this whole
series we are
so starting from if you are just
discussing about a blockchain developer
uh it is presumed for sure that you are
well versed with the technology itself
or with the the working of this
technology why it exists why uh it came
into the picture what is this buzzword
everywhere and why this is booming a lot
so uh as a whole it's being assumed that
you should know what is the blockchain
technology so if you talk about the
technology itself the core functionality
or you can say the core features of it
you are well aware of it so implementing
and designing that whole blockchain
network is something that a blockchain
developer do as well like how you design
a whole network how you implement and
support a network also and then coming
towards creates and optimizes blockchain
protocols and the very last thing that
you go with is how you develop dapps and
smart contract applications on the
blockchain network that's very important
understand those terms if we talk about
the dapps DAP is a kind of like
distributed applications that we use
these terms quite often when it comes to
blockchain developer you may have heard
from someone like okay I'm looking for
adapt developer someone who who can
develop a dab for me it's something like
we are talking about applications that
needs to be developed on the top of
blockchain technology and it could be
any blockchain like public or private
any blockchain so that is very important
if you understand these kind of acronyms
and you really know the meanings of
these acronyms that's also very uh
that's something that matters a lot so
dapps is something that you are going to
have those applications built on top of
blockchain and that's one of the part
that blockchain developer do also and
then come towards the next part that how
do you develop these daphs using like
writing some smart contracts using any
programming languages that we'll be
exploring in in the few slides
afterwards so coming towards like how
you write a smartphone contracts what
are those kind of programming languages
that is needed for you to know and to uh
to be well versed with this so you know
the uh how you're going to make it
technically feasible for your whole
career and and to get your next role so
coming towards
um what could be the type of blockchain
developer you can be because what we'll
discuss is a quite a lot of different
things if you notice the very first part
that I mentioned was that how you can
like designing the network implementing
and architecturing the solution that's
one part of it then we talked about
another aspect of how you can like um
security and optimizing the whole
um Gap development and then writing the
smart contracts and developing the
applications itself so if it if you
focus on the sides it's being divided
into two kind of two sections one is a
core blockchain developer who actually
works into the underlying blockchain
architecture or you can say uh working
on the consensus algorithm that how
these things going to be working so that
comes under the core blockchain
developer and then another part that's
important is the blockchain software
development or you can say the app adapt
developer who is going to develop the
application that's being used or that's
being built on top of that blockchain
technology so if we talk about the whole
blockchain development uh cycle or you
can say the layer
is you have one blockchain uh hosted on
which you are going to develop your
blockchain application
so first you should be clear enough what
kind of blockchain that you are going to
adopt it could be a public blockchain it
could be a private blockchain or maybe a
kind of hybrid somewhere Consortium or
hybrid blockchain and then coming
towards finding the right talent for the
type of blockchain that you are working
on then that's the next part of uh where
software developers or where you can say
developers in general lies into so
that's the next part of blockchain
developer is that how you are going to
write the smart contracts or kind of
chain codes and how you're going to make
Major's applications work on top of
blockchain so when we talk about first
thing that is or blockchain developer
they are the one who are going to work
on the core features of the blockchain
network itself so if you focus on the on
the category of the blockchain that you
will be selecting let's say if you are
going to go for the public blockchain
let for ethereum or or kind of any
application that you wanted to host in
public blockchain so that's a kind of
different thing you know your consensus
you know everything that's already
running into the network but when it
comes to a private or enterprise-based
blockchain you have a quite different
architecture it's quite bulky it's quite
vast like you have to work around what
kind of network you wanted to build into
how many organizations will going to
participate into the network what will
be the consensus mechanisms that will be
used then how you're going to set up
like let's say if you're talking about
hyper laser fabric you have to architect
the whole thing like participation of
endorsing nodes and Cas and let's say
how it's a whole MSP is going to work
and then the consensus mechanism and how
it is going to be committed to The
Ledger after going through this whole
endorsement policy so there is quite a
lot of Network Power that needs to be
done in terms of private or
enterprise-based blockchain which is not
that much required when it comes to any
public blockchain so that core
blockchain developer are the one who is
responsible for working on those side of
how these network is going to be built
into so if you just explore a little bit
about hyperledger fabric Network
Administration that's something a
separate role that's being required for
the organizations who develop on top of
hyper your fabric it's not that they
expect the programmers to do the whole
networking and who are architecting at
the base layer but they expect the the
net the network part is something that
they expect someone uh else who are
expertise who have the required
expertise in that aspect so that where
is the core blockchain developer come
into like when you talk about the
architecture or working on this
consensus algorithm and how you're going
to set up the whole blockchain network
that is one part
of the blockchain developer that you can
be now the next part that when it comes
to software development side this is
where the programming comes like how you
are going to develop your application
that is going to work on on the top of
that specific blockchain let's say if I
decided that I wanted to build uh an
application that is going to be on
hosted on onto a public blockchain so
it's a public blockchain application so
I want adapt for that like I want to
build an application so definitely you
don't need to work on to the that
underlying core blockchain layer setting
up the network and these kind of stuff
what we usually do is that we directly
go towards writing our smart contract
logic once we understand the whole
architecture whole flow of our solution
that okay what kind of smart contracts
we are needed at what stage we are
needing that smart contract act and what
is the whole flow of information from
one end to another end and who are the
participating entities and all these
stuff
once you have a very clear idea of that
you go into developing those
applications in terms of writing your
core code core program into the core
programming side then it comes to
writing your smart contracts and first
you are going to use a test Network
let's say so you're going to host it on
a kind of like test Network for ethereum
or then you are going to move into a
main net so that's the kind of things
that mostly on the side of blockchain
developer that how you are going to
write your code compile it and deploy it
itself onto the blockchain network so
coming towards that what kind of
responsibilities and the usual and the
major responsibilities that needs to be
covered by a blockchain software
developer is smart contracts writing
their smart contracts or you are
required to develop the whole
distributed applications so the reason
of mentioning this develops the
distributed application is that just
writing the smart contracts is not
something you do only you should know
that about when what what will happen
when you are going to deploy your
network and how you're going to check up
all these gas fees and a lot of the
stuff that happened there once you
deploy your smart contract onto the
blockchain network so that's where this
blockchain software development come
into and then
front and back location so we have a
kind of some middleware
um apis on which we work let's say if we
are talking about uh specifically
ethereum based development we use a
web3.js to interact with our smart
contract and to talk to our front end
also so that is the library that you are
expected to uh write the code and know
that how you are going to interact with
these two layers and act as a middleware
and how you're going to write that
specific kind of HTML code which will
link to your smart contracts easily and
the same thing that follows if you're
talking about any other blockchain let's
say in terms of private blockchain so in
hybridledger fabric when we are
developing an application for that
middle layer specifically we have
different kind of sdks that we use
that's been provided let's say by a
fabric SDK so you you you are bound to
be used like kind of java SDK or node
SDK or any kind of new sdks that being
provided to them let's say part thing is
python is in um in line as well with
them so these are a lot of things that
also involve that how your middleware
will work to talk to a front end for
your blockchain based application that
also comes under under the blockchain
development or kind of how you're going
to work as a software developer or
um or the core technical team for your
blockchain development side
so coming towards that how do you become
a blockchain developer now that's
another questions that I am going to
give you a rigid answers on that and
that's something that you should follow
but I believe that as I started in the
earlier um part of our video that you
should know uh answers of these
questions by yourself how you're gonna
do that or what you want it to be and
who you want it to be and what are the
ways to be at this stage so when it
comes to how do you become a blockchain
developer so there are a few things
that's being mentioned here it's it's a
few things I'm mentioning because it
could be more than that it definitely
depends on the type of role that you are
looking into or on the type of
organization that you are planning to uh
planning to like join in or targeting to
be the next employer for them so it's
quite uh you can say quite varied
options that how do you become a
blockchain developer but that's one of
the you can say core answers that
everywhere if you found uh the ways of
being a blockchain developer the very
first part that's very important is the
programming language because as we
discussed
the part of being a software developer
is that you should know a kind of
programming language of writing the code
into the blockchain uh in into this
blockchain whole network so some of the
programming languages that's being
mentioned here it's like Java C plus
plus JavaScript go Python and c-sharp so
as a whole I would say that is very
important for being a blockchain
developer is you should be well versed
about the basic programming paradigms
and
how a whole object-oriented programming
worked like the base pillars of object
oriented programming the reason is
that's something quite similar when it
comes to
um those programming languages so if you
talk about any of those programming
languages it's not something that you
are expected to know all of them
definitely no one is not expert in all
of these programming language but if you
are well versed with any one of them
let's say any two of them you are
expected to write your code or
understand the main uh main you can say
um main rules of writing any programming
language because you are already well
versed with any one of or any any two of
them that's very important part that
this is the core of a programming
language that you should know now how it
works into writing a blockchain based
development it's something that that you
are going to learn when it comes to any
kind of blockchain development course or
any kind of session that you will be
joining so that's something that you
will be learning as an advanced aspect
of it but the base if you know you are
that that's going to help you a lot in
in terms of your next Journey for the
blockchain development so coming towards
uh the side of writing programming
language or the side of software
development on top of any blockchain
application
there is also one programming language
that started with the smart contract so
with the with the existence of ethereum
it's solidity
so solidity developers are something
that they are exclusively expert in
writing this validity uh code or
solidity smart contracts that is being
said because solidity itself is a
contract oriented language okay
but if you just get yourself into or if
you just uh if you just go through a
little bit of how it works or
um a journal view of it you will notice
a lot of thing that is very common and a
lot of Concepts that is very related to
object oriented programming like if you
talk about how you create a class in
object oriented programming language so
that is the same thing that we follow
like how you create a contract in
objective in in solidity itself then we
have few of the uh few of the concepts
that's very much similar to it we have
inheritance in contracts we have
abstract classes interfaces then we have
a kind of aspect that how you
encapsulate things like the
encapsulation aspect of it so a lot of
things how you use a Constructor also so
there are a lot of common things that is
uh very much similar to what we already
know in object oriented programming
language so for those of you who are a
kind of confident or kind of comfortable
with any of the programming language
that we just discussed you will be able
to understand solidity very much easily
one of the different thing that you will
find in solidity is that how you are
going to play around with with a kind of
wallet with a kind of addresses how it
is maintaining uh connecting to a wallet
or maintaining an address like say smart
contract address itself and then how
it's going to hold some ethers so there
are a lot of uh things or some of the
terms or keywords that is different when
it comes to solidity and obviously it is
expected to be because that is something
that makes it unique
so these are the things that is
different when it comes to solidity
based programming language so if you are
comfortable enough in writing solidity
based code or you can say uh you are
well versed with any of the programming
languages that is in uh oop that's
object oriented programming you will Ace
the solidity side very easily so you can
Smart Start understanding the concepts
and writing those
um contracts and kind of remix IDE that
is a browser-based tool you don't need
to install anything and you can just
start compiling and trying out your
first smart contract very easily by just
installing a kind of like metamask
wallet or something
so there is a very core part of uh
blockchain development side first is the
programming language and then the very
next part that I told you already that
is fundamentals of object-oriented
programming language so we know that how
this is related to a blockchain based
development that how you write a kind of
functions how you get the details for
your users and how you use some
functions to send and receive payments
and let's say how you create a abstract
contract or there's a kind of how you
write some interfaces for your contract
so some very of the concepts that we
already know in object oriented
programming language it's uh quite you
can say similar to what we have in
solidity
then we have a kind of flat and
relational databases or you can say that
uh to understand the main concept that
how that rdbms work or the flat
databases work in terms of if you know
this kind of file storage or data
storage you will be easily
understanding that how we are talking
about the importance of blockchain
technology itself and how important this
technology itself the reason is that if
you talk about blockchain based
technology as a whole
it's just a kind of uh data structure or
you could say a technology which works
on storing of data that how do you store
data and then the architecture or the
flow of storing the data that is how it
makes it different that how you're going
to store it like either it's in a
distributed Network either it's in a
kind of um you have a ledger that is
decentralized there is no Central
Authority so these are some of the
things if you understand uh the the main
concept of flat relation database you
will be easily understanding these kind
of things about data structures and how
it's being storing this data in terms of
um in terms of blockchain and how it is
unique to any other
databases or any other data structures
also
so one of the major things also that's
written here is that you have to have
some understanding about data structures
like let's say Stacks LinkedIn list
queues so these are some of the um data
structures that we do we have so if you
understand some of them that's very
important that it is linked to
blockchain in the way that blockchain
itself is also a chain of blocks that is
linked together like it's a kind of
linked list and every block is
containing the hash of previous block so
it is changed together so kind of it is
linked together so it is it works in the
same way that we have linked list so
that's one of the reason if you
understand those data structures the the
way how blockchain works at its core of
a data structure it's going to be very
easy for you and you will be able to
understand that how this Works in in a
kind of data structure perspective
and then about some of the knowledge of
web development web app development so
that's very um common thing that when
you talk about any kind of development
side so if you know that how
um web and mobile application works and
how you create these applications and
apart from it because the concepts that
let's say if you create a mobile
application then you have some you want
to expose some apis to get data onto a
mobile application that's something very
much same that we we do in in blockchain
development also so these are some of
the concepts that you are being expected
to know when it comes to becoming a
blockchain development so the very last
part of this this points that how do you
become a blockchain developer is the
peer-to-peer networking that's something
that I already mentioned in the type of
how you understand the core concept of
blockchain technology in terms of
storing the data and then it comes to
the networking side it's really
important like let's say
those of you who are coming from let's
say
um a very old and very um basics of
computer science you must have heard
about a client server architecture so
what client server architecture do we
have a server to which all the clients
report to for any of the requests for
any of the things whatever being
accepted or whatever being provided by
the server those lines receive and work
on it and and they will be able to
perform uh next steps on it so client
server architecture architecture is
something that is centralized like we
don't have any relation with one client
to another client but all of those
clients are linked to one server or
let's say more than one server but those
servers are the one who is controlling
and who are the managing Authority
but when it comes to a blockchain based
system we don't have that aspect of
centralization
it is a core decentralized Network
that's being also said as peer-to-peer
networking why because all the peers
talk to each other and can see the
transactions whatever others are seeing
also so that's the core part of
blockchain development side if you
understand those terms if you understand
that how these things work that is one
of the major thing and then we we talk
about some of the acronyms that's very
important like let's say that is peer to
P2P and one of the things that I
mentioned earlier is daps related to
distributed applications that's also
very important and very last third uh
acronym that I wanted to mention is DLT
so what is DLT DLT is a distributed
Ledger technology so if you talk about a
blockchain based uh blockchain based
technology or
you are trying to understand this
technology as a whole
you are expected to know that okay what
is DLT itself because it is a very
important questions most of the uh most
of those who are just newly entered into
this field they know the code they know
the very advanced level of blockchain
but they are not well versed with this
term that said as DLT it is a very
important term if you just focus on in
this term is it's an umbrella term like
we have a lot of different Technologies
under DLT
and one of them is blockchain technology
so blockchain is a DLT okay but we have
other technologies that comes under a
DLT as well let's say we have hashgraph
we have
um directed acyclic graph that is the AG
then we have
um let's say we have another
technologies that we work into we have
hedera hashgraph and blockchain and many
of those technologies that comes under
DLT it's very important to understand
that the core of DLT is The Ledger is
distributed like it's going to work in a
decentralized way in a peer-to-peer
manner but how it's going to store the
data like the storage of the data it's
different not all of those Technologies
store the data in blocks so it's not all
dlts are blockchain but at its core the
blockchain is a dld itself so that's a
very Broad and umbrella term that you
should know as a as being a potential
blockchain developer make sure that you
are clear enough about these terms and
you are well versed about where and why
you are using these terms
so these are some of the prerequisites
that we discussed that okay how you want
it to be how you do becoming a
blockchain developer uh what is a
blockchain developer itself I believe at
this stage of this session you are clear
enough about two of this
what you want it to be like what is a
who is a blockchain developer so who is
what you want it to be like what could
be your next role and then how do you
become a blockchain developer so these
are as a whole is just a core steps and
then you can extend your research you
can extend your plan and make your uh
you can say whole journey that how you
wanted to reach a specific goal in terms
of becoming a blockchain developer and
getting yourself into this uh whole
ecosystem
so let's move into the very next step
that's that says the very first step if
we have got all our prerequisites that's
clear we know what we want it to be uh
we know how we are going to be at this
stage so the very first step if you
notice of of this whole system is the
first thing that you understand the
basics of blockchain
so to whoever usually asked me this
question I would say that as a whole
that's very important to to you to
understand and to go backwards to the
point where this technology started
so for the blockchain if we talk about
the very first white paper or you can
say uh one of the white paper that that
started gaining the traction for this
blockchain based technology is Bitcoin
so what you do you go towards this uh
Bitcoin white paper and try to read it
and try to grasp the whole concept
what's being written and why it came to
an existence and how this technology
played an important role in the whole uh
in this whole system that's being
proposed in that white paper
and that stage I wouldn't expect you to
be a master of blockchain technology and
even to be clear of all the terms that's
written there
but after reading that specific white
paper you should be just clear enough
what is this technology what is the
potential of this technology and either
I am interested or not like let's say
either I am convinced with what this
technology has done uh to this whole
payments ecosystem and everything so if
you are little bit clear enough at this
side you are very good to proceed
further and then what you do you proceed
further with about understanding the
core terms or core concept of blockchain
technology let's say we have uh
different types of blockchains public
blockchain private blockchain then we
have hybrid blockchain so coming towards
understanding the terms if you
understand the base term of blockchain
then you move forward with let's say
public blockchain that is Bitcoin and
after going towards Bitcoin you go and
check in the history the next step and
the next Revolution came into the terms
of ethereum how ethereum came into what
was the reason for that and how it
changed the whole game of this
blockchain ecosystem so there you are
going to explore a lot of thing in terms
of this blockchain based technology the
reason of that is that with
ethereum ecosystem
we had a lot of things that came into
the picture which was not there earlier
we got the way that how you can automate
your business process in terms of those
smart contracts and then using that
smart contracts the scope of this block
blockchain technology extended and it is
being explored that you can use this
technology out of this payment ecosystem
or out of this financial services we
have a lot of uh you can say potential
of using it in different ways or you can
say in different use cases so there come
the the potential and the power of this
this technology and if you explore a
little bit of the whole journey of
ethereum you are going to find a lot of
things that's very interesting the
tokenization aspect of it
um the mining process that how it
changed up to the latest Trend that we
have in now in 2022 so that's very
important part of the whole journey of
of learning these core of this
blockchain based technology and then
come to coming towards the base let's
say hash uh that have this cryptographic
hash is used how the system is secured
what the kind of encryption that's being
used so you can go through and um play
around with some of the you can say
demos and illustrations that's been
provided using that how your data is
encrypted how you cannot change a block
and it will break the chain so a lot of
things that you can explore in at this
step and you you know okay there is some
mining that's being provided some
consensus that's happening and the
reason of that consensus also and the
next part of knowing after knowing those
kind of terms is that how you explore
these things let's say ethereum hyper
Ledger hashgraph or Corda artery Coda
that's very important as well and other
solutions that is built on top of layer
one Solutions that's let's say we have
layered a lot of layer two solutions
into the market now but that's another
very extended form of blockchain
so as a base what we do is that you
explore
um starting with Bitcoin white paper
then you move toward ethereum-based
blockchain and then you go and explore a
little bit of hyperledger fabric and if
you are at the stage of understanding
hyperledger fabric you can look up into
the art recorder as well so a lot of
things you are going to explore in this
whole journey and you will going to
understand the basics of this blockchain
itself so if you talk about this whole
steps that we have in this whole system
in this whole systematic way
it is started from prerequisite if you
are done with prerequisites we are now
move towards step one that we have
already done that says the concepts of
blockchain and the very next stage is
that you understand economics behind
cryptocurrencies and blockchain based
technology so that's the part that is
very important you understand the whole
um whole economics in the term of the
usage of blockchain uh blockchain
Technologies in in crypto world and a
lot of it on the side of how it works in
terms of issuing some kind of tokens and
then we have token standards how you
write these tokens and the important and
the uh and you can say
um how it it the price is how you're
going to increase your price for tokens
and then we have the next era that we we
know that right now we just passes this
nfts that how nfts came into the market
and what is the best use case of it so a
lot of things you are going to explore
floor in terms of security
that says hashing that is a kind of
hashing algorithm that's being used and
the digital signatures knowing that how
this core this works as a core and then
the consensus mechanism Also let's say
proof of proof of stake why it's being
used or why there is some transaction
that transaction that being happened
from proof of work to proof of stake
knowing the benefits and disadvantages
for each of them it's very important
also
so that's one of the things that needed
to be uh on the side of
you can say more onto the side of
security or more to the side of
technical aspect of blockchain the other
part is that the economic side
on the economic side we have the
understanding that the miners or you can
say the validators who validate the
transaction are being incentivized so it
is very important for you to understand
that how you are going to be like what's
is there some calculation that's been
happening it's something some halving is
done and after that what's going to
happen if it's finished uh the block
reward is finished so what's going to
happen with Bitcoin so that's one of the
questions that if you explore that's
going to have some
um you can say
some interesting facts that you will
need to explore in this whole journey
along with it it's very important that
you try to understand about private
blockchain also if you are exploring it
try to go into going to as a whole not
just go through towards public
blockchain and you don't know the
difference between private and public so
if you're talking about private
blockchain you should try to explore a
little bit what happens with the
validators who validate the transaction
in a private blockchain so who is being
rewarded what kind of reward is being
given so you can read out some of the
use cases or some of the success stories
and case studies that's been published
to let's say onto the official website
of hyperledger fabric or Linux
Foundation or official website of
ethereum
ethereum foundation itself so a lot of
things that you are going to find out on
their own official website and for for
further you can say latest up-to-date
Trends and happenings into the industry
you can watch out to some of the videos
let's say and videos and terms that
what's being happening and what's being
announced by their like say co-founders
Founders or any of the speakers who
participated into the conference because
that's also very one of the interesting
part of the conferences if you join that
or if you follow some of the blockchain
latest conferences some of the very
um biggest uh you can say announcements
or biggest
um change that's been happening into the
ecosystem they announced usually there
into the conferences also so you can
follow up to the conference to
understand and to you can say follow the
trends what's happening into the
industry as well so the very next step
that is how uh to understand how
cryptocurrencies work that is also very
important the reason is that when it
comes to
the blockchain-based ecosystem it
started with the very first use case is
the financial use case is how you can
eliminate a middleman and do some
transaction peer-to-peer let's say Alice
and Bob they don't need anyone in
between and they can do the transactions
without any one of them so that's very
much important to know that if we are
removing the middleman
who is going to do our transaction then
definitely we do have at the core we
have this blockchain based system let's
say blockchain Bitcoin who is going to
do this transaction for us and if you if
you just go backward in terms of the
middleman we are going to have some
validator a miner who is going to mind
the Mind our transaction but things are
a lot of things that are changed when it
comes to peer-to-peer transaction uh
when it compared to the transitional and
a current system of current banking
system or financial system that we have
so that's very important to understand
how this cryptocurrency system work if
you send the money from one account to
another account let's say in terms of
ethers or not only in ethers if you are
trying to do some transactions and you
are having let's say some tokens or
something then you will be able to
um do this transaction very quickly and
you will be able to understand it very
quickly how this thing is very different
to the traditional system that we have
so that is also one of the very
important step of this uh four steps or
five steps Journey so you start with the
concepts of blockchain based technology
and then you understand the economics
behind it in which you explore the kind
of like security aspect of it the
cryptographic algorithms that's being
used and who will be rewarded and how
the reward will be done and then how you
under then you understand that how this
cryptocurrencies work and the last thing
is that you're getting on some hands-on
experience
and then when it comes to now at this
stage at the fourth stage I believe you
have a clear idea about the technology
you know the strongest strong use case
of this whole technology so far that we
have
you are well versed with the technical
terms that is being used in this whole
uh you can say in this whole technology
or what kind of consensus or encryption
or encryption algorithms or mining why
it's being happening and and the whole
flow okay and if you are clear enough at
this stage you are now able to getting
yourself onto some Hands-On or into some
querying aspect of it so for this kind
of writing some uh programming and some
smart contract you are now able to start
your journey as a blockchain developer
so this stage is very important for a
kind of how you are going to select what
kind of programming languages that you
want to be like what kind of uh
blockchain development you want to be
let's say it's private blockchain public
blockchain and then you will decide that
okay I want to write a smart contract or
I want to write a let's chain code in
hyperledger fabric that's also uh the
choice that you made initially and then
you write your smart contract and you
know that okay if let's say you are
writing it on ethereum based blockchain
you are going to publish it on ethereum
based uh Network so let's say in in
terms of test Network or in terms of
mainnet you can publish it on on the
ethereum based blockchain and then let's
say one of the major thing that's
written into the whole journey what I
appreciate it's not that you do the work
from your end and you expect the things
to happen like magically from from the
employer and or from the end of hiring
you
what is the best way is that if you make
something if you have coded something
even it's a very small application
try to
show off to it to others that what you
have made
by showing off means that you can
convince other that you have the right
talent that is required for this
specific programming language
it could be in any way like it could be
like either you go for having your own
GitHub profile maintain your own GitHub
um whole GitHub portfolio that you can
provide to others so that's the kind of
all your programs they're written you
have all your files that that you can
provide to others just to know that okay
what kind of smart contracts that you
can write
but also you can write some articles out
of it let's say if you are writing a
code in solidity programming language
and you came up with an issue of how
you're going to like you explored some
different ways of error handling like
you have different functions in in
solidity right for error handling and
from your own experience you find out
some amazing way of doing error handling
in solidity that saves some gas fees and
you believe that's a a better solution
out of what you have been already being
provided over the internet
what you can do you can write a complete
whole article on it on the basis of okay
this is my personal finding in my whole
journey I found out this is the best way
and I I I encountered these issues and
to resolve this kind of problems I tried
fixing it in this this way I wrote this
code and that's how it worked
so what will happen others will know
your problem solving skills
your skills of writing a good and solid
smart contract that's very important
so never underestimate the line of code
that you have written or the application
that you have created it might be very
small for you it might be something
that's not convincing for you but for
other or let's say to others that who
are looking up to uh as a as a a
candidate for you as a candidate to you
maybe
it's going to be something that's very
big for them so try posting whatever you
have learned whatever you have made you
can also do some participation in
hackathons let's say you you can
participate and team up with others and
create some uh very you can say
convincing and solid application in an
hackathon there's also going to add on a
lot in your portfolio and that also uh
it's very valuable when it comes to
being this whole blockchain development
Journey so
it's not something that I would say only
in in blockchain uh developing Journey
but for any of the development side it's
very important
that until you create something you are
not going to learn it in that way
so try getting your hands dirty as early
as you can and then once you are at this
stage that you created a solid
application you can just go and and post
it somewhere and create and maintain
your own portfolio so that you will be
able to portray to others what you have
made okay
and then that is very important again I
would say the whole blockchain ecosystem
or this whole blockchain-based
technology it's evolving very fast so
the developments or the happenings in
this industry it's very quick that you
don't take uh know that when what will
happen
so the very important part is that you
keep yourself updated with whatever
being happening it's not about just
keeping yourself updated let's say who
adopted uh hyperledger fabric for their
problem or who which bank adopted R3
core die and they are working on a
solution with partnering with let's say
Swift is now working with blockchain
based technology it's just the high
level that you should know
but at the core you should be knowing
what's happening inside of this
blockchain industry itself
one of the very common and uh latest
trending news that we had in the in the
past few weeks is the merch that
happened in ethereum from proof of work
to proof of stake and how they merged
this whole layers in the ethereum
ecosystem
so the reason of understanding and
keeping an eye and keeping yourself
updated is that
this technology is evolving very fast
and even the solutions and the startups
that's being built into it it's quite uh
you can say
quite quite you you you cannot expect
anything to happen maybe into the next
few weeks but there is some very uh
amazing happenings or amazing startups
that's being built upon on top of let's
say any Financial ecosystem or or for
any any industry so try to keep yourself
updated and how you do that so it's up
to you you can follow some of the latest
trending articles that's uh that's
publishing some news on blockchain or
you can also
um just find out some of the solid
connections on LinkedIn and get uh get
connected with them follow them and
treat her so that you know the latest
news what's happening there and that's
one of the reason that's important that
you visit and write some articles visit
the blogs as well and be a part of this
ecosystem
always make sure to put your input to
add your input wherever you feel you can
let's say if today after uh today you
know that okay I wanted to be a
blockchain developer and you are looking
for some of the Articles and you have a
quick thought that okay no this is how
it should be no I believe that this
ecosystem is is like growing so
scalability something that's very
important or something you can put
whatever you know and whatever your
thoughts into a comment don't ever feel
shy because that's how you are becoming
to a part of this whole ecosystem
now the very important part is what we
will be discussing next because how you
become a blockchain developer we
discussed it and then comes to what kind
of obstacles do you face when it comes
to learning blockchain based technology
so coming towards the part is that how
difficult or easy this programming
language is something that's related to
what kind of issues you face okay so
first of all that's very common and I
believe it's most of us face this issue
that the outdated content
let's see if you are working on solidity
based uh programming language and if you
are reading and following an article but
it was written for a very old version of
solidity compiler version but you have
followed the whole exact program and
your program is not working on that
latest version because maybe something
has changed and they've made it work in
in another way for the latest version
so this is very important the content
that you are following must be latest
it's not a very old content that you are
following or it's not something that
that you can say uh already outdated
okay so that's very one of the obstacles
that we would say into the solidity or
into the blockchain based journey is
that the tutorials you follow or the
content that's being written there may
be the issue is being resolved already
but you are following some content some
tutorial that's very old and one of the
second aspect is very common again is
the lack of quality content okay so the
major thing is that most of the places
where you will see that okay you will be
a blockchain developer in six weeks in
two weeks you will be a smart uh in four
hours videos a lot of videos that you
will be able to see that it's not that
they will not give you the right content
they will definitely give you but the
quality content is very important and
also
after getting this content what you do
afterwards is also very important
so the investment from your side as a
learner or as a as a potential developer
in this field is still there don't just
expect things to happen in a magic way
once you follow a tutorial and you
believe that okay I created this
application now I am a master and I look
forward to the opportunities and I
believe I will be getting hired
somewhere hopefully you will be
definitely but
how you can make your place in the
industry is that you try to create
something and then
make some updations on it let's say now
we have a lot of layer 2 Solutions also
so try to explore many of those
um
Solutions or many of those uh you can
see some of the sdks doesn't that's into
the system or some of the tools that uh
that's now just came into the in this
whole blockchain based development side
so that's also very important for you to
learn from a quality content not from
old content
now that's another very uh you can say
one of the very uh attractive part of
blockchain based development is the
salary of a blockchain developer so
coming towards the average uh how much a
blockchain developer earns is something
around
um if you talk about in in USD it's
different definitely so it it starts
from 100K per annum okay it's just a
starting I wouldn't say it's it's an
average but it's more of a start but it
definitely depends upon the size of
company that where you are looking for
and where you are aiming to let's say
for a startup it's going to be a
different or a kind of a big
organization is going to offer you a
different rate
but when it comes to uh blockchain based
uh development to any other
um core Tech development let's say
dotnet or c-sharp or even just Java as
well we have a slight difference in the
range that of the salary that's being
provided so the blockchain based
developer or blockchain developer is
usually highly paid
and one of the core reason is not that
the program the technology is booming
only
but also
the supply and demanding
when you talk about the blockchain
ecosystem or blockchain based Developers
the supply itself is like very small and
the demand is like very huge so if we
talk about the demand the demand
outgrows the supply a lot
so demand is growing very rapidly but
the supply of the development or the
supply of the developers is not very
high that's why it's one of the highest
paid when it comes to any of those uh
development side of um into this whole
software development side
so which companies and how companies are
using blocks blockchain based technology
again that's a very common thing that's
IBM Microsoft and they are using in a
different way let's say for trade
finances and we have some countries that
they are using let's say Australia and
Estonia is very famous you can explore a
little bit about estonia's case study
how they have
revolutionized their Whole Health
ecosystem the the smart card that they
have for the for the for their uh
citizens or for the residents and then
we have a lot of things that's also
evolved in Dubai also with their smart
Dubai initiative they have a gone
paperless uh with initiative paperless
they buy so a lot of things that's
happening in in different regions it's
not just one or two countries most of
the countries China has also used this
technology in a lot of different ways so
you can explore with how these
Technologies work in different countries
and different companies just to have a
better understanding of the potential of
this technology and if you were
convinced enough that okay
this technology is very booming and the
support from the government is very high
then you are
satisfied what you are doing and where
you are investing your time that's very
important and you are motivated enough
you are going on a right track you will
be able to do it very easily and very
happily
so that's a little bit of what we can
discuss in our today's session related
to how you can be a blockchain developer
who is a blockchain developer and what
are the steps to becoming a blockchain
developer so this is about our today's
session but we have different courses in
our simply learn uh course as well in
our simply learn training programs that
you can follow and that you can look up
to so you will be able to understand uh
better of what's being provided by
simply learn as for this blockchain
based technology so I wish you all a
very good luck thank you so much for uh
inspiring your time for this video in
case of any comments and questions just
feel free to post it on this simply
learn YouTube channel and the team will
be able to get back to you uh on the
queries that's being posted thanks a lot
for joining in we'll back we'll come
back for another video thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here